[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here if you're in
the gym and you're wondering what app
exercises can I do I'm good to share
with you some really simple yet
effective core exercises which will get
you a rock solid core and trust me you
will feel the burn I'll perform each
exercise for 15 to 20 repetitions for a
total of 3 sets the rest time between
each set is 30 to 60 seconds long I like
to start by working on the entire core
so the first workout is AB we'll roll
out this little piece of equipment is
the killer app workout place your knees
together on the floor hold the ab roller
firmly directly underneath your
shoulders keeping your arms and back
straight throughout the entire workout
row the wheel forward in a controlled
manner stretching as far as you can go
while engaging your core to keep you
balanced then can track your core to
slowly roll back to the starting
position do not rush the workout ok
go slow and keep your core contracted
throughout next full extension this is
another core workout I do regularly
begin by lying on your back with your
arms extended overhead and makes extend
it out I'm using a 5 kilo weight to add
more intensity as you breathe out curl
up bringing your knees to the chest as
you lift your shoulders off the floor
bring the plate towards your ankles then
breathe in extend your arms and legs
straight out back into starting position
and repeat don't use momentum to propel
yourself up engage your core and control
the movements of your legs and also arms
beginners you can start without any
weights inclined plank rock this next
workout is about small movement but your
core will be on fire so get into a plank
position on a fitness ball elbows in
line with your shoulders keep your abs
contracted and
flat your body should form a straight
line from your head to your feet
then slowly shift your weight forward
and back by moving your forearm in a
small subtle motion keep your body in a
straight line without arching your lower
back again
don't rush at the workout it's about
control and feeling the contraction on
your core sit at knee tucks one final
workout which targets at the upper and
lower abs sit on a bench with your legs
stretched out arms holding on to the
sides and your upper body leaning back
slightly keeping your chest up and back
flat throughout the workout bring your
knees towards your chest crunching and
engaging your entire core especially the
upper and lower abs then return to the
starting position and repeat if you
don't have a bench you can always do
this workout on the mat now let's move
on and target more on the obliques
another basic but extremely effective
workout is Russian twist start on the
mat with your knees bent and feet flat
on the floor and hold a plate in both
hands keeping a back flat chest up lean
back slightly and lift the feet a few
inches off the floor then slowly twist
your torso to the left and to the right
without moving your legs or hunching you
will feel your obliques contracting the
movement comes from your torso rotating
not from your arms swinging beginners
you can choose to place both feet on the
ground
plank hip dip one of my favorite oblique
workouts has to be plank hip dip start
in a basic plank position
there slowly lower and dip the right hip
close to the floor and then to the left
side engage your core keeping your back
flat and straight don't lift your hips
too high or arch your lower back and
Alex and Michael work out by targeting
the lower abs which can be challenging
captain's chair lake race if you see
this machine in the gym use it it is a
great core workout begin with your back
pressed against the backrest and
forearms resting on the upper supports
with your hands
gripping the handles keeping a leg
straight and together suck your belly in
and get your car and lift your legs
directly in front of you parallel to the
floor squeeze and hold for one count
lower them down in a controlled manner
and repeat this exercise targets
especially the lower abs and also hip
flexors if you're struggling to keep
your legs straight you can always start
by bending your knees slightly and then
progress so these are seven of my
favorite core exercises which I like to
do in the gym to give me a strong and
rock solid core what are your favorite
core exercises let me know in the
comments below you might find yourself
struggling to begin with but that's okay
stop any meet - but get back into the
workout and finish it start without any
weights if you need to and as you
progress challenge yourself by adding
some intensity so do these exercises at
least two to three times weekly and you
can combine it with my other total body
workouts don't forget to hit the
subscribe button for more workout videos
recipes and also fitness tips and do
check out the videos right here as well
all the best